hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm a property investor i've been
investing in property now for 12 years
i've done over 300 property deals
and this week you're in for a treat
because i'm going to be answering your
property investment questions so please
give me a massive favor
smash the like button and also drop a
question
in the comment box below there's no
question that can be too
stupid or too complex i've probably been
through it all and if i haven't i'll
just tell you that
i don't know so comment below and let me
get answering so we had
dream chasing so when buying a property
on completion
is it best to remove the current tenants
and give it a refurb
or keep the tenants as they've already
got a good renting
history so dream chasing 247
if the property needs a little bit of a
refurb it's a little bit run down and
you've got tenants in there
it's probably better to remove the
tenants
and give the property a lift because do
you really want a property that's a bit
shabby with probably shabby tenants
i wouldn't just buy a house that needs a
refurb and leave the tenants in
generally speaking
the only way i would buy a property with
existing tenants would be if it was a
nice property done
into a high standard the tenants are
paying a good rent so
generally speaking i'll buy it with no
tenants also normally when i buy
properties i'm going to be turning them
into hmos or i'll be turning it into
service accommodation or splitting it
into apartments
so you don't really want to just buy an
existing house
usually speaking unless it's just a
really good
buy to let property and the tenants are
good so that's what i normally do
but there's no right or wrong answer it
depends on what you want to do
muhammad says i'm interested in rent to
rent so my question is when you
walk into an estate agent what is the
first thing you say to them about rent
to rent
and when you tell them an agent is will
be done as a corporate let but corporate
let is when you rent out your employees
what if you don't have employees
but what if you want to rent out to
working professionals um
so firstly don't tell them that you've
got employers if you haven't got
employees
so you might have overheard a video
where i'm doing my kind of patter
you know you're not going to be able to
say what i'm saying exactly
because you're not me the same as you're
not going to be able to say hi i'm
samuel leeds because you're not your
name is
um muhamed so you know what i would say
is just go in
and tell them who you are what you do
we offer or i offer if you haven't got
any employees
i offer guaranteed rent to landlords and
then i put working professionals in
so i'll be doing it on a corporate let
i've got good credit
um what do you need from me in order to
make a deal do you have any landlords
that will be interested in this type of
arrangement
it's just easy now it's going to be hard
you're going to get slapped in the face
you're going to have people saying we
don't do that
you're going to have people not
understanding you but
ultimately it's about saying the right
things and
talking to the most people good luck
keep us posted how you get on
maine what legal documents do you need
for a rent to rent and also how do you
work out the return on investment on a
deal
detailed steps i have a rough idea okay
man in terms of legal requirements for
rent to rent
um i mean i did actually put in the book
property compliance made simple
there's all the details of the
legalities and everything that you need
but it's not really that complicated in
order to do rental rents the most
important thing you need is you need a
management
agreement so you need a management
agreement between you which is in your
company so there's a company left
between you and the landlord and
they're not that difficult to get i mean
you can get them drawn up by solicitors
or you can
find a templated version and tweak it so
that's what you need but your question
is about how do you work out the return
on investment so return on investment is
very simply
what you put down what you're getting
back and then you divide the two
together
so you take your annual profit divided
by your total investment
times by 100 boom shaka that gives you
your return on investment so
in other words if you're putting down 10
000 pounds and you're getting back
a thousand pounds per year
profit then your return on investment is
ten percent
which isn't good for hate for renter
rents for rent to rent your return on
investment needs to be a minimum
of 100 why because
you don't own it and you're gonna have
to do some work so
if you're putting down 10 grand you need
to make that back in your first year how
do you work that out
well you work out what your rent is
going to be your total rent
so if you rent it out room by room what
are you going to get you take away voids
maintenance and all the costs you take
away the rent that you're paying to the
landlord
and then you look at what your estimated
monthly profit is generally speaking as
well don't take on a rent around unless
the monthly profit is at least
500 pounds a month again these are just
rules of you know general rules of thumb
so
that's how you work it out i hope that
helps and i hope to see you on some
further training soon where we can bang
some deals out together
okay george lao i'm 20 years old i work
in an estate agent so i want to gain
knowledge about property to eventually
become a property investor like yourself
i have around 20 000 pounds just sat in
the bank not making me any money what
would you recommend me doing
to get started in my property investing
journey so george if you've got 20 grand
it's not doing anything
um most important thing is i wouldn't i
would first start investing in yourself
because 20 grand is not a lot of money
it won't get you very far if you don't
get creative and you don't get
knowledgeable and you don't get skills
if you go to an estate agency and tell
you you've got 20 grand most estate
agents
will laugh at you unless you go
somewhere really really cheap
up north and even then you're going to
struggle to do much of 20 grand
so that 20 grand if you want it to
really work hard you'd probably be
better off
using 10 of it or even less
but i would use 10 of it to put into
myself what do i
mean by that i mean put into training
programs books cds networking events
hotel bills when you're driving meeting
people surrounding yourself with people
that are doing this business and then
you've only got 18
then well 18 is even worse but
you've got 2 000 pounds worth of
knowledge and training
and network and exp so that's probably
what i would advise for you to do
um but hey good luck and if you need any
help give me a shout
razvan gabriel how would you invest 30
000 pounds
okay so assuming that i've already got
the knowledge okay how would i invest 30
000 pounds
um let's assume that i did have 34 and i
use 4 000
to invest in myself and build my network
in my team so 30 grand what am i going
to do
i'm going to find a cheap
rundown property um and i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna put my 30 grand down as
a deposit
i'm going to use the rest on bridging
finance
i'm then going to get a loan to develop
the property and do it up to a high
standard
add value and then i'm going to get a
buy to let mortgage and i'm going to
refinance it and i'm going to
pull out all or most of my initial 30
grand
get my money back and then i'm going to
have a free house effectively that i
rent out and get paid month by month on
that's what i'm going to do and then
wait for capital appreciation or getting
a small
rental income coming in abid
says if you have an 8-bed property would
you convert it to two 4-bed hmos or keep
it as an 8-bed hmo bearing in mind the
costs involved with the conversion to
two flats
or could you consider converting the
property into
four two bed single flats thanks
um abbott without knowing the exact
address and the floor plans and stuff i
won't be able to give you advice
like specific but my answer is my answer
is very simple
i would say look at the different
options
work out how much it's going to cost you
to do that conversion
and then look at the end values and then
just simply work out which one's going
to be the most profitable for you
so in other words if you run it as an
8-bed hmo which is what it is currently
let's say the property is worth 200
grand but if you spend 50 grand
splitting it into flats and the rent is
the same
and you only increase the value by 50
grams then it's pointless
so you just need to look at what what
your options are how much is it going to
cost
what's the end value what's the profit
if you turn it into flats and it costs
you 50 grand but then you add
100 grams worth of value then you've
made 50 grand there so that's not bad so
just look at what the most profitable
option is i'd also probably be advised
with some local agents as well i'd
probably speak to this stage and see
what the demand is in the area
you know would it is it going to be
better renting it as flats
what are people looking for look at the
supply and demand of the particular area
in mind hope that helps bash
of clans i want to get into deal
sourcing what's the best way to get
started ps the crash course
was epic great stuff so you've been to
the crash course
you know how to find deals you know to
work out the return on investment and
calculating critical numbers
now you want to start packaging and
selling deals i would very very simply
speak to some investors and say to them
what
kind of deals are you looking for that's
it
they'll tell you what they're looking
for and then if would close them
if i can find you a property just like
that
would you be prepared to pay me a 2 000
pounds finders fee those are the two
questions
what are you looking for and when they
tell you if i can find it would you pay
me a fee
find three or four investors that tell
you that they would pay you a fee
and then go find that deal for them
very straightforward all right big boss
says can you do brr strategy through buy
to let mortgage
um no not really if you're doing the brr
strategy which is by
refurbished refinance rent and you're
trying to buy it on a buy to let
mortgage
you're not buying it to let it you're
buying it to
refurbish it and then
refinance it so you don't want to get a
buy to let mortgage
you want to buy cash or you want to get
a bridging loan to do that
i hope that helps all right one or two
more questions
paul harris i found a four bed and a
five bed next door to each other
in one of the top five growth cities
three miles from the city centre
have you had experience of buying two
adjoined properties in a single
transaction is that even possible
yet to offer but the numbers show
infinite return on a br hms strategy
paul year it is possible i have actually
had experience with this
and i actually had a bad experience i'll
tell you about it anyway and hopefully
it will
help um so yes some lenders in my
experience i was buying a property and i
was buying a property next door to it
and the lender wouldn't lend me the
money
and i was like why not you'd lend me the
money on that one
and you'd lend someone else the money on
that one why won't you lend me the money
on both of them
and i think what the problem was is
lenders fear
that you'll buy two properties they'll
lend you let's say each property is
worth 200 grand
so you'll buy that for 200 and you'll
get a mortgage on it you'll buy that for
200
and you'll get a mortgage against it 75
loan to value and then
you'll knock down the walls or you put
some doors in and you'll turn it into
one
big property but that's the opposite of
brr because if you turn it into one big
property
i'm not saying you're going to do this
but this is what they fear if you were
to turn it into one big property because
you owned the two properties
and you bought them both for 200 grand
each the n value would actually go
down because you've turned two houses
into what's the opposite of title
splitting the end value might be 300
grand for the one big house
but you paid 400 grand which means that
you're now over leveraged
and the lender's now concerned so if
you're trying to get mortgage on two
properties next door to each other a lot
of lenders will be a bit concerned about
that however if that's not your
intention you're planning on doing
something different
but you just like them and they're next
to each other have a chat with a
mortgage
broker and just ask them to speak to
different lenders and see if they can
help but i have experienced it that's my
experience but i'm sure you can pull
something out the back
good job paul last question hugo thomas
if you purchase a cheap two bed buy to
let property up north for around about
70 to 80 000 pounds would you advise a
single let or rent out for
two separate tenants so if you're buying
a little cheap two bed house and you
want to rent it out
to two tenants it's not going to work
and let me tell you why
let's say you've got two beds and you're
thinking actually i could rent the whole
house out for 500 pounds
or i could rent each room out for 400
pounds and then i'll get
800 pound a month instead of 500 but
don't forget when you're renting out
rooms
you have to pay the utility bills so the
utility bills are probably going to be
a few in japan a month council tax yeah
electric
if you're paying the utility bills and
it's a hundred pounds a month
okay you might get 800 pounds instead of
500 pound but then you've got to pay the
bills so you're left with the exact same
you would have been in the first place
so generally speaking if you're going to
rent some hours a month it needs to be a
minimum normally of three people four
or more is ideal um because just bear
that in mind
normally if you're renting out rooms
they expect the bills including you need
to factor in
bills so generally speaking if it's a
two bed house i would
just rent it out as a single let to a
family home
unless you can start turning reception
rooms into bedrooms but of course then
there's a whole host of other factors
like the area and the demand
so i hope that's helpful if you want to
do hmos
service accommodation title splitting
and you want to do it properly and
successfully
i'd like to invite you to join me at my
property investors crash course it's a
free course
it's virtual so you can do it from the
comfort of your own home but just
because virtual it feels
like a real event it is a real event
it's just done from
i'm on stage with my flip chat and
everything but you're at home
logged in interacting with me so i'll
leave a link below it's free to attend
there's a one pound booking feeds to
check you're a real person
but i really hope to see you at the
property investors crash course or
just keep asking me questions on these
videos comment below or do both but
either way take massive action
i hope to see you win smash the like
button subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you
next time